josé squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve
pour faire la deuxième petite histoire
qui a été rajouté sur octobre date des
sketches on a fait la première dans un
restaurant c'était un dîner en tête à
tête plutôt romantique qui était un peu
partir en steaks et là c'est ça se passe
dans une clinique voilà donc on va dans
ces cliniques de ce parfum de cette
tentacules alors c'est une histoire pour
peaux de papa et il est dans un ring de
catch
non je pense qu'il est à l'hôpital what
je suis une infirmière pourquoi il peut
pas être un docteur non c'est une
infirmière et il fait des trucs
d'infirmières adobe mais moi je veux
qu'on soit docteur et qu'on trouve des
remèdes contre de graves maladies
j'ai tous deux ne stationne ok c'est par
où donc une infirmière qui a des
tentacules et qu'il soit extrêmement
bien voilà un an et arrêter tous me
regarder comme ça
voilà c'est non c'est un tentacule aux
fesses oui ou alors dites moi quoi faire
à trouver le dossier du patient ok ça
marche
heil et la regarde et je le vois au plat
va et été patient elle a déjà je veux
bien mais si avait pas cette femme
blonde qui me fait chier plus tard 201
203 et à tous rabon désolé battant
méfiante cette femme mais rien des blocs
quoi tentacules [ __ ] ça suffit c'est
parti on va la chambre de 100 me dit pas
qu'on va opérer quelques cas où faire
des trucs vraiment dur que bonjour je
suis là pour vous aider
bonne matinée monsieur infirmière
auxquels va me demander d'éteindre la
télé alors on va être la télé en vérité
tout péter la chambre comment l'état au
hockey la solution extrême
il faut que je pleuvent son oreillette
on leur met un petit peu moins le et est
doux et voilà il fait plein de plumes
voilà elle venait d honneur des donuts
maintenant oh oui je prends tout
d'argent et je fais le fera mais
d'aucuns donald parc au bond et baliser
ce qu'on peut le faire assez la regarder
non mais c'est pas de l'homme qu'on veut
manger bordel on veut des ciels craint
et grossière devenir obèses
thiam hommes de l'accueil avec toi mais
lui avec ses tentacules en plus il veut
il peut carrément volé des trucs quoi
dans le genre de machine nous on a le
bras bien trop court mais lui hop là je
prends la can est tout en haut ou vers
vrai business sur sa octobre à
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote c'est parti
on va lui donner
tiens c'était la manière de lui donner
allait abuser un gros merci
comme si j'avais fait un truc parfait
quoi mais laisse moi toi la blonde elle
observe on travaille tu me laisse
travailler tranquillement alors faut
aider la 203 maintenant bonjour que veux
tu es alors papa a rencontré un patient
qui était triste alors comment il faut
que je prenne sa tension mais d'armé
calme-toi regarder elle a pris la
pression elle bon derrière
j'espère qu'il va pas qui trompera pas
reposé quoi c'est bon
et mes yeux mettez de la lumière dans
mes yeux à temps mais cette fois mais
clairement paniquez pas dire vous avez
juste à rumes calmez vous s'il vous
plaît on va quand même inspecté si
jamais y'a pas de la mort dans vos yeux
oui voilà tout va bien à temps mais à
ton mais arrête de panique tu me fais
paniqué aussi bordel faut que je marque
sur le tableau et je dois à mes
questions que je te monte sur le tableau
elle veut que j'écrive un truc dont je
souhaite faire un pénis voilà je vous la
vous désolé je n'ai pas réussi
what de la main s'est envolé comme ça à
temps mais c'est bon c'était un pénis
mme mignon que j'essaie décédé un bon et
maintenant il reste à 205 ha je pense ça
va être pire truc du monde ajuster mon
lit infirmière je suis pas une simple
infirmières tiens je te tape
[ __ ] aller trop bu l'étant tentacules
octobre date pourquoi il est inoffensif
ce poulpe loi des faux que je nourrisse
tam et attend mais ce mec quoi moi je
tape aztèque
voilà c'est bien mon enfant à tanger
quelque chose pour toi encore meilleure
que la pastèque
voilà moi cette chaise bâtard suis pas
ton esclave plus tard par quoi il ya un
chapeau extrêmement cool que je peux
avoir ça c'est le chapeau pour les gens
qui sont hospitalisés monsieur voila
voila c'est bien maintenant hop ça
dégage faut que je donne un livre datant
mes mecs mais allez tous vous faire quoi
ah ben voilà puissions les livres alors
il veut des noubas pour la table
carrément équilibre dessus non non il a
passé sept 17 octobre infirmière à votre
service
tiens ton livre où il faut que je donne
une nouvelle perfusion bas c'est génial
super mais je sais où aller regarder pop
up puisque moi j'étais a fermé à toute
ma vie il y avait déjà eu même des
collègues poule donc justement ça tombe
parfaitement bien à kallo moi c'est lui
qui me disent à quoi c'est pas moi qui
sont censés vérifier sa perfusion un
tableau à la place de perfusion ça
marche ou pas c'est bon je te jure ses
mots en intraveineuse
on peut faire que la perfusion voilà
maintenant des gars j'en ai marre de ta
tête
mais toi même et en fait comme toi à mon
dieu le téléphone sonne à et au
téléphone c'est mon frère j'ai une
terrible nouvelle pour toi
l'un de tes patient a fait un arrêt
cardiaque c'est le patient de la chambre
205 mais c'est le patient qui vient
d'insulter tout va bien regardez moi ça
allait on sont lents mais tranquillement
il n'y a pas de brancards disponible
donc on fait ça comme on le peut un ânon
fallait que je remette sur le livre non
mais moi j'aime bien le traîner partout
comme ça par terre et pas du tout parce
qu'il a traité 2 nuls en plus aller bien
là sur ton [ __ ] de l'y attend excuse
moi vous faire juste un peu de place ne
bouge pas aller bien là hop là tu viens
mais attends mais laisse toi faire mais
qu'est ce que tu fais mais ce n'est pas
du tout une vengeance là que je fais
actuellement au plat à à commettre des
petites barrières de sécurité on sait
jamais qu'est ce qui pourrait lui
arriver pourrait par exemple vu arriver
les choses comme ça
finalement allé pousse-toi [ __ ] de
l'eau mais elle s'en fout quoi le mec il
faut un arrêt elle me regarde comme ça
alors tu t'en sors jeune poulpe au nul à
ok la porte est verrouillée super du
coup je dois ouvrir avec un pied de
biche mais qu'est ce texte hôpital
je ne veux jamais être soigné dans cet
hôpital allez on a décoincé la porte aux
attentions mais non mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive à tort de mecs ça fait 20
minutes qu'il en arrêt cardiaque quoi il
carrément décédé normands après bon
alors maintenant qu'est ce que je dois
faire comment je le prépare
lavez vous les mains oui oui anesthésier
le oui avec une ligue l'immense allez on
va là même la stc plusieurs fois moi ça
me fait plaisir c'est pour son bien
c'est là je crois que tu es encore un
peu mal mais pas la jambe ont fait ça
proprement tas il est chiant la voilà
c'est bon non mais mais mais mais
comment ça mais il faut que je contacte
à un docteur je crois assez la barre
docteur légale dans la survie des
opérations c'est bon il est là et là le
docteur arriva et il était célèbre son
nom était nigel mais moi les gens
célèbres je les prend pas la pose des
lunettes est gelée à je veux pas vous
gêner un cutter où sont les cas ils sont
là ya le match zoug avec lequel on a
battu steaks hachés un épisode d'avant
j'arrive monsieur n'égale vous est si
célèbre
tenez l'unpsci faut que je donne une
[ __ ] de cible à tomber il va carte usb
avec un panneau sur lequel il ya sa
famille haussé sa femme je pense c'est
bon je les tiens voici la cij commencer
l'opération à temps mais je suis un
poulpe un jeu je dois je me sens obligé
de le rappeler
or donc le mec c'est en ce moment robow
ali tu sauves ce robot faut que je
dégage tout petits un jeune simulator
bonjour veille sur aube au réveil à son
petit coeur on le voir sauvent leurs
élus un coup de main sur le coeur et
j'ai cette vision de boigne qui tape le
steak haché que cet outil ce car mon
bizarre qu'on puisse que je fais je dois
faire quoi tiens je vais sur visage
parce qu'ils transpirent est dans son
tort si l'on trouvait un coeur brisé et
reste plus rien
au final en boîte de conserve ce robot
sérieusement pour que j'attrape le coeur
comme je lai faut que donne le coeur
annie goal [ __ ] mais le coeur il
bossait de quoi y'a quoi dans ce cas on
se déconnecte tiers des vols intérieurs
plus ils ont mis une musique triste et
tout comme si c'était un moment épique
moi j'oublie pas j'oublie pas comme ce
mec m'a traitée à la deuxième jambe ou
aller jeune robot quoi moi c'est moi le
mec t'es plus un robot ne paniquez pas
madame je vais sur mes votre mari qui
est en fait un robot sur la cheville ça
marche ou pas aller sur la cheville
monga again mais [ __ ] mais attendez le
mettre sur la table ni gauche tu peux
m'aider s'te plaît parce que tu es
célèbre mais tu fous rien en fait je
tiens à le dire mais vous savez monsieur
l'effet d'un grand chirurgien s'est fait
une fac au pl de médecine à ne finisse
pas sur des moniteurs s'il vous plaît
ces machines qui coûtent très cher
iphone légal
alpha attendait à voilà c'est compliqué
oui ou encore b arrêtée hier donc en
fait pendant qu'on se check et où le mec
était par terre en train de crever mais
bon hop
et voilà il faut que j'en ramène dans sa
chambre regardez la manière dont ce mec
qui est assis sur sa chaise cause est
abominable regardez-moi ça voudrait qui
est complète pour décédé l'opération fut
un terrible succès ne vous en faites pas
cet homme est parfaitement vivant et
voilà assez les dessins voilà ce qui
dessine l'histoire la fin et voilà les
gens elle va regarder on a vu quand même
20 minutes de moins qu'à faire des
[ __ ] de pizzas et des salades à le
meilleur chirurgien qui cuisine est
quand même un bon complément
bravo à vous mes assistants chirurgien
et voilà jean se dit enfin du dlc d'octo
date c'était bien marrant de petites
histoires assez cool j'ai tâché vous a
plu ces cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la
vidéo et a fait un gros eye-fi 20 août
au nahd
d'ailleurs sa tentacule risque de rester
collé à la peau de vos cadets vont tous
dessus enfin bon au pire je pourrais
vous opérer pour vous décollez vu que
j'ai un peu expert maintenant merci
d'avoir regardé en soit on travaille
dans une nouvelle vidéo vous est temps
que tout le monde pis
[Musique]